The most important blood tests to get and how often should I order them?
So I think anybody with a serious disease like cancer should get fairly regular
CBC which is a complete blood count and CMT which is a complete metabolic profile.
On a fairly regular basis meaning that hens under your condition how regular that is if
you have abnormalities in either of those tests you should do it you know at least monthly
spoke to someone you know a few months ago and they had you know pretty strong abnormalities on
their CBC and their complete metabolic panel and the test was done you know by their
by their oncologist that colleges never went over the labs with the person. I was sent the labs
this was now I think five weeks post draw meaning five weeks after that draw was done
and you know done of them were reordered. Why you order them in the first place if you're not
looking at them to make some analysis of them and if certainly if the person has you know
fairly distinct anemia you better be running them again you don't know you know sometimes you
should be running them weekly so so it depends on what's going on. The person has fairly severe
anemia you should be really running them weekly maybe maybe every two weeks but you you need to be
keeping an eye on your patient so I don't get it you see that very often with people that are
working with a little collegeist the oncologist will order labs there's abnormalities on the labs
and either they're not addressed at all or they're not reordering lab after maybe they're told
oh you have anemia you should be unired but don't you look at them again I don't know so the complete
wellness panel that you can order off of our site has a CBC with differential complete comprehensive
metabolic profile and a bunch of other things that I think are beneficial so for somebody just to
get a good wellness panel getting that run can be very helpful. Also it depends on what's going on
if you have cancer and you have shown tumor markers positive in the past either doing a female tumor
panel or a male tumor panel depending on your gender adding that to your protocol as well. If you're
especially a female and you're dealing with hormone positive cancers then consider doing a
Dutch profile a Dutch is a complete the Dutch complete is a good complete horrible profile though
that doesn't have to be done as often so this really needs to be done just as needed this wouldn't
be something that you would look at on a fairly regular basis if it was within normal limits that I
would say maybe ever six months and you could even push it out to a year if everything was normal.
Your tumor markers it all depends on if you're using those to kind of guide your cancer care
if those show a positive getting those done on a monthly basis could be helpful but certainly the
complete metabolic panel and the comprehensive CBC would be done on a more regular basis.
The question that came to me directly was recently a CBC results shown some markers
like ferritin to be extremely high. If I said you those CBC results with the cheek swab can you just
add additional supplements or should I schedule a call. You should probably schedule a call.
So I mean those results now I have a software that I put all those results in that is really kind of
cool and it gives you a really nice readout and more often than some of these things aren't being
addressed so if ferritin is very high what is that usually indicate well that usually indicates
some people think that ferritin is only an iron marker while ferritin can indicate iron levels and
iron transport levels because that's how iron is transported typically a ferritin is elevated
it's an inflammatory marker so if ferritin is elevated and you're currently taking iron make sure
that you stop taking iron so but send me those those and we'll and then schedule a talk that we should
go over that.